All right.
We're on problem number 9.
At least for the next few, I
don't think I have to copy and
paste these problems.
I can just write it.
It looks like a little bit of
algebraic long division.
Problem 9: They want us to
divide 2x plus 7 into-- it's
pretty long so I'll give it some
space-- 2x to the fourth
plus 21x to the third plus 35x
squared minus 37x plus 46.
This might look daunting,
but once you
start, it's not so bad.
So like any long division,
you kind of look
at the biggest place.
And the largest degreed place,
at least in this polynomial,
is the 2x place.
And that's what we work with.
So we say, how many times does
2x go into 2x to the fourth?
Well, let's see.
The 2 goes into the 2 one time,
and x goes into x to the
fourth x to the third times.
What's x to the fourth
divided by x?
It's x to the third.
So we say it goes into it
x to the third times.
And if we were right, when we
multiply, we should get 2x to
the fourth.
So x to the third times 2x
is 2x to the fourth.
And then x to the third times
7 is plus 7x to the third.
If this was some other-- well,
we'll worry about it when we
get to it, but you would want
to put it under the
appropriate place
in this number.
It just happened to be that x to
the third was the next one.
Now you subtract just like you
do with regular long division.
These cancel out.
21 minus 7 is 14x
to the third.
And then you could bring down
all of this, but we can worry
about that in a second.
So how many times does 2x go
into 14x to the third?
Well, 2 goes into 14 seven
times, plus 7, and x goes into
x to the third x
squared times.
If we're right, when we
multiply, it should work out.
So 7x squared times 2x is equal
to 14x to the third,
like we thought it should.
7x squared times 7 is what?
That's plus 49x squared.
And now we subtract.
14x to the third minus
14x to the third.
That's 0.
Now we have 35-- we could bring
this down, just because
it makes it easier.
35x squared.
35x squared minus 49x squared.
Let's see.
So it's minus 14, right?
49 minus 35.
So it's minus 14x squared.
And then 2x goes into
minus 14x squared.
So 2 goes into minus 14 minus 7
times, and then x goes into
x squared x times.
When you multiply this minus 7x
times 2x, so you get minus
7 times 2 is minus 14.
x times x is x squared.
Of course, you have
to multiply it
times both terms, right?
We're multiplying it times
this whole expression.
Minus 7x times 7 is minus 49x.
Now we're ready to subtract
again and I'm
running out of space.
These cancel out.
We could bring this minus
37x down, so minus 37x.
Remember, we're subtracting
this, right?
We could almost add
the negative.
Let's make the negative.
So this is minus 37x minus minus
49x is the same thing as
minus 37x plus 49x.
I made both of those
positive just to
simplify it in my brain.
Oh, whoops.
I didn't want to go
down that much.
OK.
So these cancel out and then
this is equal to 12x.
And 2x plus 7 goes into 12x.
Well, now, let's see.
2 goes into 12 six times, x goes
into x one time, so then
this is equal to plus 6.
6 times 2x plus 7.
6 times to 2x-- I know you
can't see it-- is 12x.
And then 6 times the 7 is 42.
We have a 46 up there.
I should have written smaller.
So you get this 46.
And now we're ready
to subtract again.
12x minus 12x is 0.
46 minus 42 is 4, so we
have a remainder of 4.
So let's see, our answer
is all of this
with a remainder 4.
So all of that plus the
remainder over what we're
using to divide into:
2x plus 7.
So our answer, let's see
what choice it is.
It's x to the third plus 7 x
squared minus 7x plus 6 plus 4
over 2x plus 7.
We just took our remainder and
said, OK, whatever this is,
that's also there.
So that is choice-- let's see, x
to the third plus 7x squared
minus 7x plus 6 plus
4 over 2x plus 7.
So it's actually choice
d is our answer.
I was just reading choice a.
I should have shown you that.
So choice d is our answer.
Next question.
Problem number 10.
That one took up more space
than I expected.
Problem number 10.
Which polynomial represents-- so
they want us to multiply--
this how they write it-- 3x
squared plus x minus 4 times
2x minus 5.
I find that we should just
multiply these the way I would
multiply any number.
So I would rewrite it as 3x
squared plus x minus 4 times,
and I put the same degree under
the same degree, times
2x minus 5.
And now let's take the
0th degree place.
I guess you could
view that way.
Minus 5 times minus
4 is plus 20.
Minus 5 times x minus 5x.
Minus 5 times 3x squared
is minus 15x squared.
2x times minus 4 is minus 8x.
I'll put it in this place
because that's our x's space.
2x times x is 2x squared.
And then I should have had all
of this-- actually, I think I
can do that.
Let me see if I can move all
of this to the right.
The magic of computers.
I can move it all to the right,
although I should color
that back in.
Let's see if I can color that.
Look at that!
All right, back in business.
All right.
So I did 2x times minus
4 is minus 8x.
2x times x is 2x squared.
2x times 3x squared is
6x to the third.
This is a plus.
Now we just add up everything.
So we get 6x to the third minus
15 plus 2 minus 13x
squared minus 13x plus 20.
So 6x to the third minus 13x
squared-- I'm just checking
all the choices-- minus
13x plus 20.
That's choice b.
Problem 11.
Let's see, they wrote-- this
is problem 11, just so you
know what we're doing.
Minus 2x squared plus 6x plus
1 minus 2 times 4x squared
minus 3x plus 1 is equal to--
well now, we just have to
simplify this.
Let me rewrite this part.
This is minus 2x squared
plus 6x 1.
Let's distribute a minus 2.
So minus 2 times 4x squared
is minus 8x squared.
That's that.
Minus 2 times minus 3x,
that's plus 6x.
Minus 2 times 1 is minus 2.
And now, let's see.
We can add the like terms up.
Let's see what this
is equal to.
Let's do the x squared term.
So first I'll do the minus 2x
squared and minus 8x squared,
so that is minus 2 minus 8,
that's minus 10x squared.
Let me do another color
for each of them.
Then I have the x terms. I
have 6x, and then I have
another 6x.
You add them together, you
get 12x, plus 12x.
And then you have your ones
terms or x to the 0th power,
you can view it.
You have plus 1 and minus
2, so that's minus 1.
And then that is choice-- let's
see, let me scroll down.
That is choice d. minus 10x
squared plus 12x minus 1.
Choice d.
Problem number 12.
Problem 12.
We're on a roll.
Problem 12: Which expression
is equivalent to-- so now
they're multiplying.
They write 6y squared minus
2 times 6y plus 2.
You could do this in your head,
and you should practice
doing it in your head, but if
you never want to make a
mistake, you just write
it like this.
6y squared.
And I have nothing
in the x's spot.
And I say minus 2.
And then this one is 6y.
I write that in the y spot.
This is y squared, this is y,
this is y to the 0, which is
just 1, plus 2.
And now I multiply them.
2 times minus 2 is minus 4.
2 times 6y squared
is 12 y squared.
So I write that in that
spot, 12y squared.
Now 6y times minus
2 is minus 12y.
So that'll go here.
And then 6y times 6y squared
is 36y to the third.
So we have our answer.
It is-- you just add them up--
36y to the third plus 12y
squared minus 12y minus 4.
And that is choice d.
And you could do this in your
head, and that's a good thing
to practice.
But I just wanted to make sure
it was clean when I did it.
And let's see, should I continue
with the next video
or should I stop there?
Because I'm at 11 minutes.
I'll stop there and I'll see
you in the next video.